have you ever heard of a company called
it Huawei a few years ago they overtook
apple and it became the world's second
largest smartphone seller while this is
awesome for Huawei and China it may not
be all that great for the rest of us if
you've been following international news
you probably know that Huawei has a
sketchy past when it comes to
surveillance and the data collection
now this is nothing new given that
basically every tech company does this
but there's one key difference between
most tech companies and Huawei
most tech companies collect your data to
craft effective marketing campaigns and
sell you stuff
conversely Huawei allegedly collects
your data for the Chinese Communist
party in fact in 2019 the US actually
outright banned Huawei in the country